SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Today's our great honor to
have Her Eminence Dagyum Chenmo
Kusho, also known as Dagmola,
visiting Google and giving us
a talk on women's social role.
Dagmola was born
in eastern Tibet.
She fled to India in
1959 with her family
and moved to the United
States a year later,
where she helped
her husband found
the Sakya Monastery of
Tibet Buddhism in Seattle
in the 1980s.
In addition to taking
a full-time job
and raising five sons, she
took all necessary trainings
to become a qualified
spiritual teacher.
She is also actively engaged in
educating younger generations
on spiritual development
and has founded a few Dharma
centers in North America.
As featured in the
book "Dakini Power,"
Dagmola is considered one
of the most influential
female Buddhist
masters in the world.
So it's a great honor for us to
have Dagmola here and give us
a talk.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: In
the Tibetan language,
it means auspicious greetings.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Greetings from Seattle.
Well, I would like to start by
thanking all of the organizers
and especially my friend
Jessica [INAUDIBLE]
for inviting me here, come
here to talk about social role
of the Tibetan woman.
I must say that I am
honored and humbled
to be at the presence of such
brilliant and innovative young
minds.
I am Tibetan old woman
practitioner, was born in East
Tibet, and a strong
background in Buddhism.
And later I married Sakya
Dagchen Rinpoche in Sakya.
And as many of you
know, we have in Tibet,
there's four centers
for Tibetan Buddhism,
and Sakya is one of them, which
we call Nyingmapa, Kagyupa,
Sakyapa, and Gelugpa.
And Sakya Dagchen
Rinpoche's father
was the 40th throne holder
in the Sakya in Tibet.
So I married, lived in the
palace with many servants
around.
And then in 1959, we were
forced to out-- to exile
from Tibet, like
all other Tibetans.
So then we lived in India
a short period, but then
the University of Washington
brought us to research--
teach and research to my
husband, Dagchen [INAUDIBLE],,
as well as my uncle for
the three years' grant.
So since we cannot go back
to Tibet because the--
still the Tibetans
are under the Chinese,
so we emigrate to a state
in the United States.
So then I was working like
any of you, like working hard,
raising, like he mentioned,
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned,
five children to put
in school, so forth.
So I try to keep
up with the growing
change in the modern world
and all its modern gadgets
and many cities.
I have seen much,
experienced much,
in over 80 years
that I have lived.
Today I speak to you
through my experience
as a woman and especially as
a wife, mother, grandmother,
and great-grandmother and a
Tibetan woman and a Tibetan
Buddhist practitioner.
So very little was knowing to
the worlds of Tibetan women,
and then we lost to
our country in 1959.
Since then, large
number of us lived--
have lived in exile,
various countries.
We have learned to
adapt to the culture
and language of whatever country
we found ourselves living in.
However, no matter where
we are and no matter
what challenge life
threw at us, we
are strong as people and gender.
Tibetan culture is filled
with strong feminine roles
and model.
So especially like Tibetans
always decided major things
and from mother.
As we are deeply
spiritual people,
very often our role models
are the female deities.
We have Arya Tara,
the mother goddess who
regarded us all her children
and guiding and protecting
us and taking care
of, which Tibetan,
we call Dolma, which is savior.
She made a vow to save
all sentient beings
from their suffering and be
reborn in female form in life--
all the lifetime.
We have Ushnishavijaya,
who is also goddess
who give us a long life.
One of the most powerful
protective deity
is the female deity which
we call Palden Lhamo, who
is also protected as wrathful
form and created and fear all.
Names like Machig Lapdron,
a famous female protector
of the 11th century,
who initiated
several practices of the
spiritual development
and [INAUDIBLE],, who help us
to spread Buddhism in Tibet,
helped us the great reverence.
Women were not very active
in the political field
before we lost our country.
There have been
many Tibetan women
who were involved
in the politics
of the regional governance,
but such a prominent
was not so invisible in
the central administrator.
But for example, what I recall--
for example, I recall if the
leaders, kings, the husband
died, women take over.
For example, like Queen of
Dege, a region in East Tibet,
ruled a region until her
young son attended majority.
Queen [INAUDIBLE],, who
was very popular leader
and did much that promoted
literacy and learning
during her regent.
There was other
Tibetan women who
played prominent roles
in tribes, especially
in East Tibet.
Tibetan women have always
had strong roles of family.
All the family, if they have
some big decisions, and always
made by mother.
Many household are
ruled by matriarchs.
An old Tibetan woman were--
let's see.
Matriarchs.
OK.
And then old Tibetan women are
mothers and business owners,
nomads, and farmers.
In fact, it was not uncommon
for the Tibetan woman
to be married with two husband
or three husbands at same time,
and most are their brothers,
living in harmonious
in the same household.
Of course, it was for
the particular purpose
of keeping the land undivided.
In such a household, women were
always one who rules the roost.
A large number of Tibetan
women, 4% become nuns.
And also Buddhist nuns.
The nunneries were
places of learning,
and women could pursue an
education, which was not really
available for the young girls.
In fact, both men
and women turned
to monasteries and
nunneries for education,
as these instructions were the
sole providers of education
in the old days.
Secular education was not
widespread at the same time,
like my time.
This is kind of a silly problem.
Silly-- I tell you
something I remember.
When my aunt-- my aunt was in
a nunnery, lived in nunnery.
I visited the
nunnery quite often.
I enjoyed very
much with the nuns.
They have beautiful voice with
the chanting and the singing.
And I try to make the--
like wear the nun clothes and
cover my hair with a towel.
And I enjoyed very much,
I'd go visit in the nunnery.
But I never wanted to be a nun.
The reason why, as you
know, in the Tibetan,
no matter what part of
Tibet, east, west, central,
all over, Tibetan
girls or women,
they wear all kind of jewelries
covered with their hair
and the headdresses.
So I always see they are
so beautiful, you know.
Because Tibet, in my
time, at that time,
we don't have banking
system, and the jewels
was the asset in the family.
And the man may have
horses or rifles or swords.
That's what we have.
So it's just like
silly, I said, you know,
I never wanted to be nun
because I cannot wear jewelries.
That was-- and today, when
I think back, it was silly.
So losing our country
and living in exile,
Tibetan women have played
a very crucial role
in preserving our culture and
tradition in the foreign lands,
like myself.
Now in exile, Tibetan
women are well
represented in the
political fields and members
of parliament, ministers,
and hold positions
of power of decisionmaking
in the various administrative
offices.
Today, Tibetan women are
doctors, nurses, teachers,
lawyers, business owners,
authors, and other occupations.
Like I was talking to
the girls in the Google.
I'm sure you have
thousands, maybe 10,000.
There two Tibetan
women are working here.
So that was-- I was
really happy to know that.
So this is what Tibetan
women today can do.
So Tibetan people are generally
known as peaceful people
due to our spiritual practice
of generating loving kindness
and compassion for all beings.
We strive to feel great
compassion for others
as it does for ourselves.
In order to help to motivate
us in this practice,
we are taught at the
early age regarding
all the sentient beings
as the one's own mother.
A mother is regarded
as a compassionate one
who for nine months carries
the child within her womb
and who continue
to love and nurture
her children well into
becoming adult. So this is--
we have to thank them all.
A mother is the [INAUDIBLE] of
loving kindness and compassion.
So in our culture, the mother
is regarded with great reverence
as life force and nurturer.
So we also think,
mother protects a child
until the child gets
eight, eight years old,
even protects--
the mother's shadow
protects the child.
So therefore, women are
treated with great respect
and are equal partner
in their homes.
And the Tibetan
also now the exile--
before exile, you know,
Tibetan is like, you know,
all the culture, like
we have heard of--
Tibetan women exile and lived
in many countries, especially
the United States.
Many thousands.
And first when we came, we
don't have education background
as well as a language problem.
So many Tibetan women
worked in nannies,
housekeeping, and so forth.
So I have heard that Tibetan
women are very much demanded
as nannies and caregivers for
both young and old people,
because they have compassion
and talk to them when
they are young.
It is their kindness
and compassion
that makes them provide
the best to carry and love,
even for those that are not
their own blood or race.
Today working mothers are truly
superhuman in their abilities
to multitask between their
work environment and their home
front.
However, women are
still women and bring
warmth and a
softness in whatever
and whenever they are doing.
Now in Tibet-- now in
the Tibetan families,
in before, many parts
of Asia and Tibet,
it's always when the
family have a child,
they always like to have boy.
It's like many parts
in the world before.
Now, in the Tibetan family,
when the girls was born,
the parents expressed
great joy, and they
will have someone who will look
after them after they get old.
So the-- you know, times change.
So Tibetan women, like the
women around the world,
have faced a challenge
due to the gender bias.
However, we have very
compassionate spiritual leader,
His Holiness the Dalai Lama.
Through his many
initiatives, His Holiness
has encouraged Tibetan women
to be part of governance
and social economic
growth in exile.
Even recently, in
2016, last year,
His Holiness confirmed a
Geshema degree on 20 nuns
in South India, which is the
first in the history of Tibet
and the Tibetan people.
The Geshema degree
is Geshe, a man
compatible to the doctrine
and the philosophy.
And the degree is
confirmed after 21 years
of rigorous study of
five main Buddhist texts.
This is the step forward in the
[INAUDIBLE] in Tibetan women
as education is the key to
changing and development.
I would like to
envision to future
where women are equal partner
in all the field of life.
In the workforce,
I would like to see
women be equally compensated
for her time and effort.
I hope this, that they
will come to a time
when women are not afraid
to go where they want
and what they want to do.
At home, a woman is the
daughter, sister, mother, wife.
Home should be safe,
even from all trial
and challenge of
the outside world
if they are around in the home.
Unfortunately, the world
is not perfect place,
and women will continue to
face discrimination at work,
abuse at home, and a disparity
due to the whole gender.
It is true that
even today, there
are countries where
the women are treated
little better than cattle.
However, we can still strive
to change the plight of women
all over if women are
united in the common cause.
If they are afraid--
if they are afraid,
tell other woman.
We need to speak openly.
If you are abused,
tell other woman.
If you are happy,
increase it by sharing--
sharing your happiness.
If you are sad, lighten
it by sharing your story
with someone.
We live in the age of
social media, which is
powerful tools, all of you now.
So resolve yourself
to being a woman,
embrace other women to form
a strong circle of support.
Women can be a great pain.
Like woman is the one
who brings the child.
Women have to go through
all the pains, not men.
But men have to realize
how to share what pain
is going through the woman.
And come out-- but if
even it is painful,
come out shining in the end.
We are a mother, wife,
daughter, and we are strong.
If we should have more
female leaders in the world,
we would be more
peaceful place, and women
have the innate quality
of patience and compassion
and no war in the world.
Like Arya Tara, we
should feel honored
and proud to be born
in a woman, and we
can do much as women of the
knowledge and compassion.
Tibetan women are
always strong, and we
remain strong since our
exposure to the outside world.
We are inspired by women in
the West, who stand shoulder
to shoulder with men
while still holding down
in the fort at home.
I am inspired to African women--
African-American women
who made sure their voice
were heard in their
movement in the civil right.
I pay homage to all the great
women who have come before us
and struggled with the
restraint of time and prejudice
and who have made the path
easier for us now to follow.
So this is part of
our Tibetan women,
how went through,
we still how are.
So if you have any question.
SPEAKER: I thank you,
Dagmola, for your thoughts
during this inspiring talk.
So I will take this chance
to ask the first question.
So just imagine that
you think that women
should take a more
leadership role in the world,
in the modern world.
So I wonder what kind
of Buddhist teachings
can help women to become
more confident and more
capable for taking
the leadership role.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Well,
Lord Buddha Shakyamuni
teaches us no gender.
Women, men, any
age, any race, it's
equally we can be enlightened.
Equally.
But the world is a little bit
crazy and misunderstanding
and things.
It is getting
better, but I still
think women should be
strong, and they should be--
how do you say it--
have own courage
and think that we
are happy to be born
with this, and we want
to help with whatever we can.
And make yourself-- don't
try to lower down, to make
think we are all equal and the
teaching says all are equal.
It's like that lay practitioner
or Tibetan monks, lamas, are
all practitioners and
equally enlightened when they
do the right path, right route.
It's most important,
is motivation.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
And also I'm particularly
interested in Sakya lineage,
because I know that so far, all
the foreign holders of Sakya
lineage have been male
members of a Sakya family.
I wonder if in the future
maybe a female member
can also be a leader.
Do you think that's possible?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Very
good, good question.
Just like I mentioned earlier,
in the Tibetan Buddhism,
there is four sects in Buddhism.
And like those, all
four sects, many
have reincarnations, which is
just like you already know,
it's like Dalai Lama is
like 14th reincarnated.
And so is Karmapa,
17th reincarnated.
And that's unlike Sakyapa.
Sakyapa originally descended
from celestial realm, a person
from celestial realm,
and married with a human
and produced children.
And that's why lineage carry
on, there is no reincarnation--
father to son.
So this is-- it's different
than reincarnation.
And so other lamas still
recognize reincarnation.
Like we all-- we all are
somebody's reincarnation
anyway.
So that, unlike the
Sakyapa lineage.
And like [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned, yes, it's true.
Up to my time, it is
always the male system.
And I heard a lot
of Sakya history
when the lama married
and don't have a son,
and then maybe have to marry
second or third wife until it
brings son.
And so I remember myself, when
I got married with my husband,
my father-in-law gave a
blessing with name change
like also says bring son.
So likewise that, but
today's different.
But they have-- if
they have a daughter,
daughter is equally teach Sakya.
Any teaching.
But daughter, son, is not be
the Sakya current lineage.
They are the current lineage,
but it's not the same.
It's male.
So that is different.
But it's just the
Sakya is always
the lineage, father to son.
When they passed
away, they will pray
to be born the same family.
This is up to over 1,000,
maybe close to 1,000 years.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
I understand this is
a tradition, and--
but I think there are a
lot of good female members
of the family, and they are
very good practitioners,
Probably even though they
are not the throne holder,
maybe they can also
take on leadership roles
to help grow the Dharma teaching
and also help the family,
help the community.
Thank you.
OK.
So let's take some
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: As a Buddhist,
my husband always
say, you do chanting and
reciting, mantra, sutra,
and you also make
lots of donation.
And how would,
oh, the things you
did benefit me and our family?
This is my first question.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: That is good.
Yes.
If we are connected, for
example, myself, for example.
I have lots of
friends and students
who kind of relied
on me and ask me,
and I will do this
sincerely to [INAUDIBLE]
to help whatever their needs
and heal their suffering.
And this is the--
yes, you can.
Like I mentioned
yesterday, there
is teaching what to donate
and the giving and the taking.
That's why.
If you pray, your
husband will help, yes.
Even he doesn't
believe in Buddhism,
there is always
some blessing there.
AUDIENCE: And my second
question is, would you
please share your
wisdom about emptiness,
so that way I can
share with him?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: That
is a big question.
Yes, I know it is.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Emptiness.
Emptiness, we talk
a lot emptiness.
But it is always
the essence there.
Is everything phenomena,
it's like emptiness.
Never the same.
It's changing.
Changing a lot.
But essence is there
to what you call--
it would be like reborn, and
everything is never the same.
It's just implemented.
But at same time,
there is essence there.
So that's the big question.
But if you practice
Buddhism, you will learn.
Each of us has some
wisdom leading us.
If you really follow
that, to concentrate,
do some meditation, then will
show that what to do next.
But to just start
talking emptiness,
emptiness means
everything [INAUDIBLE]..
It is everything, emptiness.
But there is essence in there.
AUDIENCE: And my third question
is, as a lay practitioner,
especially for a woman, how
to balance their family life
and also practice buddhadharma?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: I usually
call Dharma is daily life.
Those are the lamas,
monks, and nuns.
They have nunnery, monastery.
They stay.
They're supported, and
they do all the praying.
But lay practitioners
are like husband, wife.
We have to raise children,
go to school, work, so forth.
Every day your life, just to--
you know, Tibetan Buddhism also
says human life is precious.
Most precious in the life,
which means we have opportunity.
We can do things.
We have physically.
We have everything
around, especially us
and all the teachers and
teachings and living,
everything, freedom.
So since you get up in the
morning, you should be happy.
Oh, I'm happy.
I'm still alive.
I want to do something for
good myself and my family
and extended for my
neighbors, whole world.
And this is thinking, that's
the positive thinking,
positive attitude.
And that helps lead
through the day is happy.
And that is part of your Dharma
practice for lay practitioner.
But everything you do, you think
something do right and helping
others with from sincerely.
That's why I always say,
it has to come from heart.
You want to help
somebody and give--
maybe get something back.
Don't think that.
You have to do unconditional
work, unconditional love,
unconditional how you
do your own children.
So this is-- will help.
So you can never say, you
know, any lay people were--
can be enlightened if
they have that right path.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Always
good to know this.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: For every woman
it doesn't matter anyways.
It doesn't matter.
Had to have good heart.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have one question.
If I may ask is, what's
the most challenge
you're facing you think
when you fled from Tibet?
That is my first question.
I mean, the most challenging
thing you think you had.
Do you have challenges think?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Do myself?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: I don't recall
I've done tremendous things,
but I feel I'm good.
I have done something
in this life
so benefit others, try to teach
something positive, and raised
my family, and try to go
to teaching wherever I can,
whatever I can do.
And I lived this.
I'm 84 years old.
I still maybe a few
more years, who knows.
And so I always thinking
in myself, I'm very happy
and can do this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you, Dagmola, very much
for come and give the talk.
One question I have is, you
mentioned 4% of Tibetan women
become nuns and that there
are nunneries in Tibet.
Is that still the case now?
There are still quite
some nunneries in Tibet,
or this is in the old age
before you left Tibet?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Yes.
I just recently visited
in Tibet last month,
and I was offered support
at many nunneries.
And those nuns there,
some are nunneries.
Only problem there is limit.
You can have so
many, each nunnery.
Before, anybody who wish to go.
But nowadays, each nunnery
has allowed so many nuns.
We have around Sakya, there
is two nunneries I visited.
One is, like, 250 almost.
One is, like, last time I
visited, only 25, now it's 37.
But they have limited.
They have to get pass-- kind
of passport from government
to get in certain things.
Otherwise, yes, there
are are nunneries,
and these nuns are very
good practitioners.
And of course, nuns
in India and Tibet.
And they have debate like
monks, and they do very--
and I also heard
some people, patrons
who want to ask pray for
monastery or nunneries,
and they like to do nunneries
because nuns sit still there,
and they do until pray done.
Monks maybe not do it, some
might get up and walk out.
So anyway, these are very good.
And then old nuns, like
my time before, there
are still nuns, I heard,
still in the cave do
practicing all of their life.
But like I said, before the
Tibetan came out in exile,
women are not out, because man
is lamas, monks, [INAUDIBLE],,
so many of-- so the women are
not really even practitioners.
They do the retreat.
They do their own practice,
not so much go around
and teachings.
But now they are, yes.
AUDIENCE: So the teachers
at the nunneries are nuns,
so there's no, like, male lama
teachers at the nunneries?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: I will
say, most nunneries
have just nun, [INAUDIBLE],,
but some lamas who
are qualified lamas,
[INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE]
can go give a teaching,
certain Mahayana teaching,
so they can practice.
But like Mahayana
practice, we have
to have received
certain teachings.
Without receiving
transmission and teachings,
we cannot practice.
So yes, the male lamas go there,
teach, and not live with nuns.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So in general, the Buddhism
teachings in the nunnery,
are they very similar to the
Buddhist Institute or monastery
for monks or anything
special for nunneries?
Or maybe not as
stringent as the monks?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Oh, you mean--
AUDIENCE: The teachings.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: --Tibet and
India and those places?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, just compare the
nunneries and the monastery
for monks.
Are these very similar?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Very similar.
Yes.
They are very similar.
And even now, nuns have
more, like I just mentioned,
His Holiness gave
a Geshema degree,
which is equally is, you know,
Geshe, which means doctrine,
degree.
And this is just first time
happen in Tibet history.
So nuns do debates,
and nuns do all
of what the monks are doing.
Teaching, yes, equally.
AUDIENCE: Yesterday, you
mentioned about your exile
from Tibet and
climbed the Himalayas.
Just imagine that it is still
very difficult for nowadays.
So would you please
share your insight?
How come you can be so strong?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: I think leading
by [INAUDIBLE] and Arya Tara
guide me and help me, like
all other people who are
to guiding from [INAUDIBLE].
But it's true.
When I came out from
Tibet with three children,
the youngest one is just about
a year old and still diaper on,
crossing the Himalayas.
And it wasn't easy.
But we left country because we
don't want to give up Dharma.
That's why we left.
And then like I said, some time
in my life, I lived in a palace
in Sakya.
I raised by my wonderful
family in East Tibet
and lived in Sakya, married
with head of Sakya [INAUDIBLE],,
and lived in palace.
And then crossed the mountain
and the refugee camps,
and then came here [INAUDIBLE]
from the Rockefeller Foundation
for three years' grant.
Ever since, we cannot go back.
So here, I had to do--
I wrote this book, first book.
I think I see--
and I give the first book
to His Holiness Dalai Lama.
And he was very
happy, and he was
saying that this is very
good because it gives courage
for the other Tibetan women.
Because you were in Tibet,
you were first lady,
and here you're American
servant, which is true.
I worked.
Mother, grandma, everything,
I [INAUDIBLE] working for.
Tibetan, now American.
Yes.
So that's why now
since after I retired,
I try to do as much as practice
myself and help the others
teaching.
Not just women.
Men.
Anybody who needs in my
own experience, my sharing.
I also grateful, lots
of men who supports us.
Thank you.
I'm only talking to the women,
but men are wonderful helper.
Lot of things.
Yes.
Without, like, Arya
Tara even said,
there's no men if
there's no women.
It's equally.
But she wanted to remain--
reborn with a woman to
come help all the beings.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And my last question
is, there is-- recently
there is a movie called
"Wonder Woman" here.
I feel the--
I was so touched by the
Wonder Woman's compassion.
And so when I saw yesterday's
topic, "Dakini Power,"
is there any special
training for us to,
female, first female, to receive
some kind of special training
to become more powerful
to have the [INAUDIBLE]..
Because that is so beautiful.
DAGMOLA SAKYA:
What kind of power?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I just--
DAGMOLA SAKYA: I only just
would called it the spiritual.
And you have to--
in Tibetan Buddhism, you cannot
just pick up a book, read.
All you can say, lots
of my Western students
will sometimes say I'm
Buddhist, many years.
I've read so many books.
I went to lots of classes.
But that doesn't
mean you're Buddhist.
In Buddhism, it's
necessary, you have
to receive the
refugee vow, which
is some commandment there.
And after you receive that,
then if the teacher and student
have commandment,
teacher [INAUDIBLE]
would protect you, guide you.
And the students
follow that guidance.
But finding teacher
is very hard.
Today, I would say there's so
many young teachers, lamas,
and all kind of--
I don't even know lots of them.
But you have to really
find right teacher,
not just follow their ranking or
their look or they dress good.
Only look what their background,
carry the transmission,
lineage.
Who are their teacher?
Then you go for it.
Once you have it, you
don't need many teachers.
And you'll follow that.
That's Mahayana Buddhism.
There is many teachers.
Some are good.
Doesn't matter, man,
woman, nun, or monk.
Doesn't matter.
It's just something that
answers your question.
Something you're connected.
Usually we can tell once
first we meet for talk,
you kind of tell that.
And most times, people goes
just look, all written so much
about background.
His Holiness.
All those.
That doesn't mean anything.
You have a connection.
AUDIENCE: And from what you're
saying about this connection,
I told my husband, if
I saw, like a formal--
I feel connection.
But my husband will
say, that's not--
it's not logic.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: So what
should I answer him?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: That's OK?
All right.
Leave it at that.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
about our software engineering
profession.
So in this profession, there is
actually a misbalance of our--
the genders.
There's a lot more
guys than girls.
So what do you think could
help to balance the genders?
Because to me, it seems
very good for a woman
to work for a company
in the software industry
because it's possible
to work from home.
She can take care of her
family when she needs to.
But what do you see are the
obstacles, and how can we help
attract more women to help
balance this industry?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: I
think that we all
know be nice, listen, and listen
what they want, how they talk.
You may have-- you may can
help, she may can help you.
You may can help her.
So this is just--
gender is really
not much difference.
Only the connection
with your thinking
or your wisdom or your related--
or most in Tibet
we'll call it karma.
We always related.
And mostly I would always
say to best things have
to be nice with your parents.
And the parents, if you take
care of parents, especially
mother, you will be happy life.
And this is the only--
when we pray, we
always-- every prayer,
we say all mother and
all sentient beings.
Because we considered that
some time, I was your mother.
Maybe yes.
Who knows who we are?
There's something like
we are here today,
just there is some connected.
I believe.
Every time I believe that I have
somebody to closer and talking
or feel, and is
there some lifetime
we had some connection.
So it's most important, patient.
And especially
women need patient.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Be
very sensitive.
Women are more sensitive,
so you be patient,
then you'll always find the
right path through your wisdom.
SPEAKER: OK.
I want to ask the last question.
So because you are now
living in the Western world
and especially like in
companies like Google,
we have very diverse
background, people
come from different
countries in the world.
They have different religions
and maybe a lot of atheists.
They have different
belief systems.
So what do you think
is the best way for us
to promote Dharma teachings
or to help more people
in Google or in the society?
DAGMOLA SAKYA: All
religion, I respect.
All the religion,
spiritual, they
are helping all the beings,
whatever they need, always.
But what we need is
everything in today's life,
we just too fast.
Everything new all, you'll
have to have that new.
You don't need it.
So slow down, think,
do I really need this?
Things, materials, too much.
And also when you
have something,
somebody said
something you didn't
like to hear, be just patient.
Listen.
Not answer right away.
So this kind of helping for
calmness and communication
and peace for the world.
So this is because, like
I mentioned yesterday,
some people have one you
need again another one.
If you have the one
car, I need better car.
Just like iPhones.
Everything.
It's too much things.
If you know how to work,
that might be helpful.
World needs lots of things.
For example, I have an iPhone.
I only know how to
[INAUDIBLE] or to call.
It has fancy things,
but I don't know.
So why I need that?
So somethings you do need,
sometimes you don't need.
If you have one car,
you need second car.
You cannot drive
two cars same time.
So it's just slow down and
do a little meditation.
Doesn't have to be Buddhist.
Just little bit down, with the
patient, talking, anything.
Just think more than do more.
I think this leads to easier
and peace for everyone.
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
Thank you again for your
inspiring talk and your wise.
And also thank you
for the hosting team
and all the audience
for your time.
Thank you.
DAGMOLA SAKYA: Thank you.